yep, it's alive. Good morning
everyone.
We're so honored to have
everyone here today. On
behalf of the library of
Congress, Dr. -- becomes
everyone this morning. We're
exciteed to have
everyone here today. Today's
program is in -- keep
his memory alive by supporting
programs like this
this morning. We would like to
spotlight Marsha and
barny here this morning who
would love them to stand
and be acknowledged by this
amazing crowd.
(APPLAUSE).
Their generosity has allowed us
to do
programs like this.
By the way, this week
is children's book
week. That either one thing we
can agree on, that
books brighten a someday, it's
like the light of the
room. When I was a kid all those
Dr. Seuss books
were my favorite, when I became
a teenageer and it's
going to show my age were the
hardy boys books,
there's the John Greene books, I
can go on and on,
but you're very lucky with the
selection of books
you have nowadays.
We're lucky to have
schools here from
district. When I call out your
school you need to
have a major cheer.
First is thorough good
Marshall school.
There was a slight pause there,
I thought
they weren't here.
All right all right.
The school
--
I think they did something here.
I know we're going to
one up each other.
All right the seed school.
And the last one the Washington
global P T
S.
They also have all of you here
today so
one big round of applause for
all of you.
(APPLAUSE).
Now, you're not the
only teenagers
watching by the way, today's
event is being streamed
on library of Congress website
and You Tube channel.
So everyone watching online,
hello.
A lot of love from
Washington.
And you know, we want
to say hi to all the
kids watching coast to coast.
We got to simmer it
down now.
All right now we're
here today to talk
about a major moment in civil
right's history.
Several months ago,
about a year ago, the
moving loving came out and it
was based on this very
important Supreme Court decision
. How many of you
heard of the loveings? The
adults say yes, we're
hoping before this morning is
over we will educate
the students here today.
Believe it or not
there was a time in
American history that white
Americans and African
Americans could not get married.
It's very hard to
wrap your head around but that
was a dark time in
history and you could be thrown
in jail if you got
married.
Mildred and Richard
who was white lived in
not so far Virginia, when they
were arrested and
sentenceed to a year in prison
just because they were
married. Really hard to imagine
that now.
There their case went
all the way to the
Supreme Court, and 50 years ago
this year they won.
Their case changed laws across
the country so it --
no one can decide who to marry.
We have the author
here today and the book
I will administrators who has
joined us here on
stage. We're also joined by an
expert lawyer and
educator, I have Beth Hayes
Patterson, she's been
teaching laws for almost 40
years and her speciality
is race and the law.
I'm lucky to introduce
her, she's been a
friend of almost a decade -- she
has been a mentor,
teacher and just, you know, I
used to work at the
Pratt library with Deb and we
come a long way from
the today show to this morning.
So please Deb Taylor
will be leading today
today's discussion. Thank you
for joining us and
I'll pass it onto Deb.
(APPLAUSE).
Good morning, and it's
good to be with you
to Gus this uncredible book that
the subject and the
people who liveed with this
history with eloquence
and care, because this story is
so important to who
we are as a nation we're going
to place in social
and historical context, as he
told you I'm joined by
an esteem panel, they'll each
give us brief thought
busy the work and the time
that's it depicts.
We're going to begin
with a brief video
about the landmark decision that
we commemorate
today.
(VIDEO)
I think marrying who
you want to is all
right it's a God given right, I
think.
Mildred loving married
the boy next door
-- they were born and raised in
Caroline county
Virginia, where they seemed un
aware of the prejudice
that existed across the country.
But they didn't
know it was a crime to marry a
knee grow in Virginia
Virginia, they found out the
hard way.
I didn't realize how
bad it was until they
got married.
Their homes with
children, their own three
as long as neighborhood friends,
she recalls the one
night in 1958.
The night we were
arrested, I guess it was
about 2 a.m., and I saw this
light you know and I
woke up and is it was the police
man, and they said
told to us get up and we were
under arrest.
You go ahead and play.
Anyway, they
and locked us up. And January
they had the trial. And they
told to us leave the
state for 25 years. They said we
can come back to
visit when we wanted to. So that
Easter we came back
and they got us again.
They found out we were
there and they
arrested us again.
They spent five years
where they suffered
-- was hit by a car --
the Robert Kennedy who in
turn passed the letter on a
member of the simple
libertyies 89.
We have children and
cannot afford an
attorney, we wrote to the
Attorney General and
suggested we get in touch with
you for advice,
please get with us when you can.
Hope to hear from
you real soon. It was a simple
letter that got us
into this not so simple case.
They did help the love
ings. Came up with
another attorney and with no fee
they opened the
plea, until the Supreme Court
heard these arguments.
We advance the
arguments that statues are
slavey statutes, -- the
outrageous of these statutes
are not always apparent right
away.
For example, if
Richard loving were to die
then Mildred would not be able
to collect benefits
as his which do. We asked the
court to decide that
the state may not pass a law
that describes marriage
base on race alone.
The attorneys for the
state of Virginia re
refuseed to talk with A BC.
They seemed to say
there was a present day
justification for these laws,
that is they're
interested in the welfare, the
children of such
marriages.
Today the United
States Supreme Court
handed down the decisions.
Richard and
Mildred have
the right -- it's included
--
This A BC news report
ing.
(APPLAUSE)
.
Before we begin we
would like to remind
the adults in our audience that
the last 20 minutes
of the program are for questions
and answers between
the students and the participant
s on the stage. If
time allows and there's no
students in theat the
microphones we'll take questions
from the adults.
They danceed
throughout the Americas and
America with her dance company
one plus one before
becoming a story teller and
writer of children's
books. The diseaseeling baker
has won various honors
honors, illustration, Boston for
non-fiction,
non-
non-fiction and parent's choice
gold for poetry.
Her documentary novel
loving versus
Virginia, guild selection for
2017 and her middle
grades is forthcoming in 2018 --
designed writing
and illustration and went on to
finish her MS A in
New York City.
For new talent in 2009, for her
first
fiction book bird.
She coillustrateed our
children can swore
winner of a image award.
Conducting workshops, share
her work with children, teachers
and lie bareians.
She currently teaches
the -- she's a asset
to Baltimore arts leading the
effort book making
competition to Baltimore city
public schools, thus
encourageing the next generation
of artists and
writers.
She is currently the
associate director of
law school here in Washington
D.C., she's also an
center. Before
joining the law center she
shared as chaired and was
commission of DC commission.
She taught conflict of
law
, contract race,
sales transaction and civil
rights movement.
She's serveed as
associate Dean for program
programs at law center with
responsibility for the
supervision of character program
s. She receiveed the
law center faculty award, she
won the FC award.
Thank you, good
morning everyone.
Well, first I have to
give a shut out to
two schools, I have to recognize
those from the
thorough good Marshall. It was
started by two
Georgetown graduates and a
special welcome from seed
public travel school.
So I want to pick up
on something you
heard in the tape, and that is
one of the lawyers
referred to the fact that what
they wanted to do was
to address the law, that was a
message of slavery.
Let's begin the legal
discussion by going
back to the post Civil War
period.
There were three
important amendments that
were adopted at that time, and
the goal was to
fundamentally change the status
of the formal slaves
slaves. So the 13th amendment
abolished savvy, the
is is 15th amendment gave the
right to vote,
denied the ability to vote on
the base of race. That
only affected African American
men, African American
had to wait another 50 years to
get a right to vote.
14th amendment which
was most involved
in this case is the a.m. L
amendment that guaranteed
two things that an individual in
this state could
not be deprived of life, libbity
without due process
of law and the second is to
guarantee theial
protection of laws in the state.
So what did equal
protection of the laws
mean for the formal slaves? The
Supreme Court
answered that in 1896 in a
indication titleth
--
came out of the state of
Louisiana, it had a law
that said that black people and
white people have to
be separateed in railroad cars,
they cannot sit each
other. They challengeed that law
and he assumeed with
the package of the 14th
amendment and woman
treatment under the law that
that law would be
instruct down but it doesn't
happen.
The Supreme Court
determined that the
states could separate people by
race as long as
things were equal.
So, this doctrine of
separate but equal,
was a doctrine that lasted for a
long time. And
allowed states to pass laws
which they did, that are
required or allowed the
separation of people by race
in movie theaters, in restaurant
s, in libraryies, in
restrooms.
During that period of
time also was when
Virginia passed the racial
integrity act, if you
look at the slide, it's in the
bottom middle, the
Virginia
bulletin explain this act and
it says that
white and non-white people
cannot marry and if they
do it's a crime.
So this is what we had
as law, separate
but equal. Laws like the state
ouvriers that
prohibited marriage between
people of different race
races, until 1954, and in 19 a 4
, the Supreme Court
decide the case of brown versus
Board of Education,
I'm sure you all heard about it,
that was where they
looked at this whole separate
but equal doctrine.
And same slide, to the left,
bottom left, brown
versus board of education, when
the court says when
it comes to education, separate
is inherently un
unequal, meaning there's no way
there's equalityity
when the state says black
children have to go to
school here, white people have
to go to school there
there. Totally unacceptable.
That ushered in what
we called the period
of a new civil rights movement,
if you will, and two
important events happened the
next year in 195 2, in
August of 1955, 14 year old
Emmett Till was in
Mississippi and was murdered and
murdered why?
Because of aalleged he insulted
a white woman, how,
he either whistleed or he said
something to her,
that's it. And then in December
of 1955, I know you
remember Rosa parks refused to
give up her seat on a
bus in Alabama Alabama and a
boycott started.
So that is -- after
that in 1935 a -- 1955
1955, the state of Virginia
announceed it would
massive resistant in Board of
Education -- on the
slide, lower right, you see a
reference to Harry
bird who talked about that fact.
Virginia resisted
so much that they close the the
public schools
rather than integrate them.
There was one county in
Virginia, prince Edward county
about 90 miles from
here, where the schools stayed
closed for five years
years, from 1959 to 1964.
So that is the
atmosphere within which
Mildred Jeter and Richard loving
had their
relationship begin.
So you can see we have
a very dramatic
time, but we're talking about
people who are living
their lives, and who are not
necessarily caught up
in the drama as we saw on the
slide.
So, now we come to the
that story, and I
want to start by asking Patricia
, why? Why this
story? For this time when so
many of our young
people don't know this history,
or may not be able
to apply to heme, why did this
story compel you to
write about it?
It's a story of love,
the name of the
couple, the loving, their name
was loving, and they
were very much in love and I got
to tell a love
story, and in among the civil
rights movement, all
the slide you're seeing
on Ginger Elizabeth were
pages of the book as these in
property of you, and I
came from a very socially
conscious family and we
saw by example that when when
somebody needed help,
you helped. So it was a very
compelling story for
this reason. Do you want me to
go into the research?
>>
Sure.
Okay, we have the
bulletin called the
racial integrity act, was put
into place in Virginia
until 167 when the U.S. Supreme
Court favored
of
interracial marriage. What it
says about 2/3 down
there are people in Virginia who
are posing for
white but they're not really
white. If you are 1/16
1/16th Native American then you
can call yourself
white if everything else in your
family is white.
But if you're 1/16th African
American and
everything else is white you are
not white, that
means you got one with great
great grand parent who
is African American then you are
not a white person.
So what it's saying is there are
people in there pre
presending to be white who are
intermarrying and you
may not do that and if we catch
you it's against the
law.
So on the right we
have the photograph of
the white classroom and the
black classroom, and
this is under the separate but
equal law that Ginger
was mentioning the -- does that
look equal to you?
Toes two classrooms?
So,
can I have the slide change
please?
I did my research in
eastern -- in
Virginia, Caroline county where
the family lived in
a very integrative neighborhood
and segregated state
this. is Mildred educateor's old
er brother -- I talk
talked to family members and
friends of the family
and the place is very important
here because my
story starts in 1952. The movie
started when they
get married in 58 when Mildred
is 11 years old and
Richard is about 16 or 17 years
old, and they grew
up in this neighborhood together
and I got stories
from family members of what
happened in their lives.
Doing this research I
used primary sources
and I thought it was interesting
to see how messy
they are.
On the very top one it
reads Richard
educateor a white man and --
Richard loving -- they
don't dignify her to give her
name, she's white and
she's black and her name is not
on it. But here is
her arrest want and she was
arrested in bed in 1958
after they were married, and
then another -- and
then they were exiled. We know a
lot of the story
said they were sentence to the a
year in jail or 25
years exiled. They lived in the
slum in Washington
D.C. much.
So that was 58 and in
1963 they tried to
get the case, the A CLU lawyers
Bernie Cohen and
Phil Hirschkopf back into the
court by bringing to
Lee I don't know who was the
judge for the case and
he wrote remember raceist
statement, which was very
helpful to the A CLU lawyers
because it was so race
racist, and what he said was "
Almosty God,
all might
mighty God created the raceist
yellow, black, and red
and placed them on different
continents, his
arrangement there would be no
cause for such
marriages. The fact that he
separated the raceist
shows he did not intend for the
races to mix.
Mildred thinks about
this and says this is
a nation of red people, spilling
by white people and
the I don't know if she really
said that, this is a
documentary novel means it's an
information a.m.
book but I told it in voices of
Richard and Mildred.
You talked about some
of the document
that's are part of the book and
I think that creates
a particular context for
opportunities, and I have
to ask you because it's unusual
to have a book
that's written for teenagers
primaryily to have
illustrations, what do you think
your illustrations
brought to your book and story?
I teach at the College
of art and a class
called visual journalism, where
we draw on location
and I wanted to use these draw
ings and some real
context but they wouldn't be
appropriate for picture
book for very young readers, my
agent is like let's
just put it on the website and
see what happens,
they charactered me about
contributing to this book
so I got really lucky basically.
But I think the
illustrations add more of
the love story and you can see
behind us is one of
my favorite illustrations of
Richard and Mildred
spilling away to run through the
woods and spend
time with each other.
When I talked to the
art director and the
editor at chronicle, we really
wanted to focus on
their lives as individual people
, as opposeed to the
law and other interference with
their life. I think
the illustrationsadd that level
of softness and
hopefully a bit of magic between
the two of them and
showing their chemistry and
their love for one
another, and illustrations are
nice. They're
beautiful drawings in the middle
of sort of intense
legal documents and then the
story itself, so.
Elizabeth, I remember
that news clip, I'm
old enough that that's not
something new to me so
see the news clip when the
decision came down, I
also remember that there were
states as late as 2000
that were just removeing the law
s from the books.
What does that mean, if anything
? Why were they
holding onto those laws if it
had been struck down
through the loving case?
Well unfor can'tly,
laws are very slow to
act of change. I can't say I
can't read into the
minds of legislatures, and that
was in Alabama, and
so I can't say that it was an
act of defiance, I
suspected it was maybe a little
of that and a little
of just not wanting to do it,
not thinking it was an
important thing to do.
The important thing is
despite the fact
that Alabama did not remove the
law from the books
until 2000, the law was changed
once the Supreme
Court made the decision, that
was it, so.
One of the things that
stood out for me
from reading the book was even
though there were
social restrictions on Richard
and Mildred, when
they were in Virginia, Virginia
was home. And one of
the things that comes across
both in the
illustrations and then the
poetry is the fact that
that was, even with all of its
problems it was home,
how were you able to get that
across, this whole
idea of the distinction between
being exiled, so to
speak, and then wanting so
desperately wanting to
come home?
May I talk?
Yes, please.
It starts in 1952 and
my dread is 11 years
old and Richard is back ground
because he's friends
with her big brothers and it
shows how they grow up
together in this interracial,
idealic setting they
had families, they were
self-sufficient farmers, so
after hog parking lotteringing
and neighbors came to
help there would be a big party
and Mildred's older
brother and father played in the
strategic band and
they were the enter Al at the
same time for the
neighborhood, beautiful commune
ity of whites, blacks blacks
and Indians together who had a
wonderful life and to
be exiled in Washington was so
very different, they
lived in a very small apartment
and it was dirty and
there were lights on all the
time, opposeed to the
nature, the natural world around
them, it did not
feel like Earth to Mildred to be
in Washington wash,
she wanted the scene of her cold
and her family, a
very close anytime family and
the neighbors were all
friends.
>> Could you speak to
the book design.
Sure -- I grew up in
Georgia in Atlanta
and the civil rights movement
was the topic of
conversation at the dinner table
all the time with
my family, so making the
illustrations I couldn't go
back in a time machine and draw
them as they grew up
up, things felt very familiar in
my writing with my
own mother and siblings with the
way we manage
communey, so it was helpful to
grow up with that
experience torque be able to
make it real in the
illustrations.
The book design
chronicle makes really
beautiful books, you'll see the
book, it's gorgeous.
I really love this
orange cover, hard
cover that we have, but I felt
like we worked
closely together and sort of
talking about the mood
that we wanted to portray in the
story, and I'll
show you -- can we get the next
slide please?
The next one.
Okay, one more.
That one.
So, the first thing
that we understood
going in is we wanted the book
to be printed in two
colors, during the day when
printing was more
expensive and you could on print
with a limit number
of colors, so here in these
slides some of the cover
R conversations that I was
having with the designer,
most of time I don't get to work
with the designer
of the book, but because I have
design background we
were able to have intelligent
conversations. I sent
maybe for or five color choices,
I was in love with
this green and rusty red color
combination but if
felt a little too heavy and we
got to this purple
and gold when they overlapped
made a nice rich
background which made illustrate
ing I will dread, so
it worked out and it was great
fun to be able it
work with chronicle. A big part
of visual journalism
journalism, back in the 50's
Lee owny wasbrought
virtual illustration to the
forefront and hired them
to do what they wanted to do,
there was a lot of
trust that had to go into that
Rich and I felt
chronicle gave me that when we
were working on this
book together.
I think we have one
more a little bit of
discussion here, and I would
like to talk about the
14th amendment for a moment,
since so much of the
indication imageed on that and
you made register to
it in your opening remarks, and
how were they able
to zero in on the 14th amendment
and to make their
case when they had not been
successful at all of the
lower courts? Was it because
they were with a more
systemic court or were they able
to craft a story or
craft a way of understanding the
14th amendment
that won their case?
I think the lawyers
assumeed they would not
prevail in Virginia at any level
and based on the
history of the state that was
accurate. We refer to
the integrity act, but Virginia
and Maryland were
the two colonies that passed law
s prohibiting enter
messenger, and this is a very
long history in the
state of Virginia. I don't think
they crafted
different arguments, they made
the same arguments
with respect to the equal
protection --